- Commençons par le privilège
de l'informateur. Ce qui est
au coeur de cette décision de la
Cour d'appel d'une cinquantaine
de pages. Pourquoi c'est si
important? Et pourquoi c'est
au coeur de cette décision?
- C'est un principe extrêmement
important. On part du principe
que, au Canada, et heureusement,
la justice, elle est publique,
surtout en matière criminelle.
Les procès sont publics,
les gens peuvent aller au palais
de justice voir des procès
et les jugements sont rapportés,
les médias peuvent rapporter
ce qui se passe dans une salle.
- C'est fondamental.
- C'est à la base de notre
démocratie, pour s'assurer que
la justice est effectivement
bien rendue. Parce que la
justice, c'est pour le public,
alors il faut la confiance
du public. Mais il y a des
renseignements qui doivent
demeurer confidentiels pour
impératifs de sécurité et de vie
privée. Il y a ce qu'on appelle
les privilèges. Et un des
privilèges les plus importants,
c'est aussi importane e e le
secret professionnel de l'avocat
qu'on connaît tous. C'est
ce qu'on appelle la protection
de l'indicateur, protection
des informat q q qui tendent
à révéler l'identité d'un
informateur. Pour que la police
puisse mener des enquêtes,
elle a besoin d'information.
Il yeseses gens qui ont de
l'information à donner sur
des crimes, révéler des crimes,
donner des détails, mais qui
veulent pas témoigner à la coure
que si je collabore avec
la police, on ne va pas révéler
mon identité ou des informations
qui pourraient m'identifier,
par peur de représailles.
Et c'est un privilège
qu'on dit absolu.
- Absolu.
- Ça veut dire que la justice,
les juges et les tribunaux
sont obligés de protéger
les informations qui révèlent
l'iden d d d'un informateur.
- Mais certains pourraient
se dire : la date du procès, le
nom du juge, le lieu du procès,
est-ce que réellement, çututut
permettre d'identifier la
personne? Est-ce que certaines
informations auraient pas,
tout de même, Me Hijazi,
pu être dévos s s sans menacer
sa sécurité, à cette personne?
- C'est une question de
préoccupation légitime.
Là, on va rentrer dans les
particularités de cette affaire-
là. Ce qui a été reproché
au départ, c'est que le procès
s'est tenu entièrement
dans le secret. Il y a pas
de numéro de dossier,
il y a pas d'inscriptions
dans les ordinateurs
du palais de justice.
- C'était même pas dans
un palais de justice que
ça a eu lieu.
- Les seules personnes qui
savaient qu'il y a eu ce procès
sont ceux qui y ont participé.
Ça, la cour d'appel dit que
ça va trop loi. Sur des
renseignements particulier
comme le nom du juge,
le district judiciaire, etc.,
le nom des avocats, c'est un
aspect qui a été soigneusement
étudié par la Cour d'appel,
qui conclut que  c c ce cas très
particulier, ici, qui est quand
même assez unique, ce sont des
renseignements qui pourraient
tendre à révéler l'identité
d'un informateur. Alors, un
renseignement qui, à première
vue, peut avoir l'air anodin
pour le public, une information
insignifiante, pour ceux qui
sont concernés, qui sont visés,
par exemple des complices,
ça pourrait révéler l'identité.
- Est-ce qu'il y a pas tout
de même un risque de dérive,
ultérieurement? Un précédent
qui pourrait mener à davantage
d'opacité, ce qui pourrait mener
à une perte de confiance envers
le système de justice.
- Encore une fois, c'est une
préoccupation qui est légitime.
Mais je ne m'en inquiète pas. La
justice, elle est transparente
au Québec et au Canada. On est
dans l'ultra-exceptionnel, pour
ne pas dire unique, d'une part,
l l la Cour d'appel a dénoncé a
façon de faire la première fois.
Il y a pas nécessairement de
mauvaise foi, on voulait bien
faire. Les protagonistes,
la première fois, étaient animés
par l'intention de protéger
ce qui doit être protégé,
c'est-à-dire l'identité d'un
informateur. Mais on est...
La procédure, la manière
de faire était exagérée.
C'est très particulier.
On est dans l'unique ici.
Et la Cour d'appel, qui est le
tribunal suprême pour le Québec,
dénonce cette façon de faire.
Alors, je suis pas inquiet
pour le futur.
LeLeLe tribunal suprême pour
le Québec, mais certains disent
que ça pourrait se rendre
en Cour suprême. Le croyez-vous?
- Alors, c'est à suivre, c'est
à voir. Je veux dire, il y avait
plusieurs requérants importants
ici, il y avait plusieurs
médias. Il y avait le procureur
général du Québec. Le ministre
de la Justice avait exprimé des
préoccupations quand ça a été
révélé il y a quelques mois.
Il y a aussi la juge en chef
de la Cour du Québec qui voulait
avoir un accès limité au
dossier, mais a demandé accès
et sa demande a été refusée.
Ils ont un droit d'appel.
Est-ce qu'ils vont faire appel
à la Cour suprême? On verra.
Ils ont 60 jours.
- Merci beaucoup, Me Hijazi.
- Je vous en prie.
- Au revoi